C5 oh and oh wow okay meanwhile a game
has started the Armageddon between
Magnus Carlsen and Shakira mamajarov
mamajarov with the white pieces and a
quick start to this one it's the English
opening a couple of pieces off the board
already at this early stage yes and uh
I'm just going to briefly mention that
you guys wanted a Hikaru confessional
and we have a Hikaru confessional and
we'll play that during the break
and there we see Shaq stepping up with
his Queen side Pawns
ah
A4 on the board from Shaq stepping
forward with the queen side pawns and
okay Magnus just basically playing a
sicilian but with reverse colors uh
looks healthy to me black set up here
Judith who do kind of holders the
favorite at this early stage well I like
Black's position as it is pretty healthy
I'm not sure this A4 is
it's there but of course in this
position white Bishop from C1 it has a
challenging test that where is it gonna
go or it will stay there forever
interesting A5 move which was done by
Mama jar of pushing the pawn if black is
not going to be stopping A6 then I
believe mamajiaro is planning to push
all the way and also probably Queen A4
is something that he might be continuing
or queen B3 but I'm kind of surprised to
have this spawn push on the A5 it's
especially so early in the game you know
you're kind of taught that you have to
develop your pieces
and Shaq is saying you know what I'm
just going to attack on the queen side
and just whoa I was not expecting that
shuck is determined that magnus's king
lives on the king side
a shack attack is real but he's
forgetting to develop his pieces White's
pieces do not look ready for this
opening of the position Judah well nine
years ago when I stopped and competitive
chess this was not the way it was
considered the way to success
that is true but push all your pawns and
without developing you have one
developed piece on G2 it's just very
strange yeah but now he's going for your
planetly student putting some pressure
on this Black Knight but the problem is
I mean yes there's pressure on the Black
Knights but take a look at why it's
night on G1 how is on Earth is that
getting out
probably the next move to play Knight F3
yeah but then Bishop H3 is also
something to think of I can also imagine
that in the next move let's say black
plays D5 or F5 making it a more active
play with black
yeah I understand what Shaq is trying to
do he's trying to open the position
because he has Bishops but he's just not
ready to do that and actually it's the
side who's facing the bishop pair who
should be trying to speed up the play
here so yeah Magnus it looks like he's
got all of his pieces in the game nice
centralization everything holding
together
time Advantage is disappearing now it's
less than a minute and a half difference
between the two I think in terms of
start to this game not super promising
for managerov Magnus could he go 7 out
of seven in the armageddon's
I spoke to him on the rest day and I can
reveal he said he was shocked that he's
holding his nerve in the Armageddon he
says he doesn't know how it's happening
uh of course he said he'd give
everything for one classical win but the
Armageddon is where he's doing the
business and okay Pawn 6 pawn and okay
question here take that pawn with the
Knight or simply recapture it with a
Pawn on E5
[Laughter]
kind of we laughed at it a little bit
but it's a great in-game porn so
definitely oh I spoke too soon
it is excuse me game game as the Queens
leave the board yeah if it was anyone
else in the world I think Magnus would
have taken with the pawn but against
getting the Queens off tends to be uh
good wisdom there
so Queens have left White's Pawn
structure
not necessarily the worst well black
probably wants to go Bishop C6 to
eliminate the white square bishop and A6
spawn can be a weakness also in a later
stage yep your prediction came true and
those Bishops will be leaving the board
I promise black Luck's Pawn breaks now
or Lux effective Pawn breaks so it feels
like white is at least got some level of
stability and those Bishops traded as
predicted
but is White's A6 Pawn enough to give
Shaq serious winning chances
because remember shark playing with the
white pieces is in a must win situation
yeah this white A6 born could be backed
up nicely by White Knight if you could
imagine a teleportation device this
White Knight on H3 somehow landing on V5
attacking these pawns but right now it
doesn't really uh kind of make a great
impression I was just thinking about
that dude and be fine but how do I get
there right not G1 then I have to do
what Knight E2 somehow but then E3 Pawn
is hanging you need uh nakamura's Knight
to dance around uh you need a similar
Journey could you put it on A3
but then it gets but then it gets
stopped by a Pawn on C6 anyhow
what to put it to A3 it's also B4 should
be but you just don't reach that spot
Magnus breaking out in the center and uh
in terms of the clock situation remember
Magnus did start with a three minute
deficit over chakra
Magnus has just got a four and a half
minutes whereas Shaq has six and a half
minutes
and Magnus withdraw odds will want to
play solidly I think that influenced his
Queen trade decision and now this last
Pawn push I said he didn't have any pawn
breaks I just assumed he wouldn't want
to undouble White's pawns whites C pawns
here uh here kind of traditionally not
favoring white but Magnus is happy to
trade off just to get his Knights active
and there we see
both the Black Knights now in the middle
of the board beautiful settings for
black look at two Rooks on the open file
two nights in the center is just ideally
placed yeah just beautiful
centralization but he has to move one of
them the Knight on D5 was attacked hits
the white Rook now
but that night on B4 is going to get
anchored there with the C7 Pawn
and wow White's position is beginning to
look like
it's not good and there you go C5 I mean
there's no coordinate coordination
whatsoever with white pieces well
finally there is a little idea that the
right place let's say Bishop D2 and
somehow when the Knight moves away from
B4 Knight F4 to D5 can jump in
yeah he starts with the other move order
say my dear Judith uh first some
pressure though especially the white E2
Pawn the base of this chain uh it's a
bit vulnerable you have to over protect
this Pawn somehow uh before the White
Knight gets kicked away from its
protection and you need to keep this
chain intact otherwise your whole
position falls apart sure
H4 looks good just to prevent Pawn to G5
and okay he you chooses instead to use
his King to defend the E2 born and a
question mark making White's position
worse C5 Knight D4
oh or immediately jumping in first big
big threat on the board black wants to
play that move you mentioned Judith G5
hitting kicking away the White Knight
then the E-2 Pawn will fall
so how to deal with that I think he has
to push the pawn uh the H Pawn to cover
that threat what else you don't want to
touch anything around your king you
don't want to touch your Pawns
you'll only weaken them instead he
brings his Bishop out to block the black
Rook on the E file it feels shaky well
it's holding together for now for white
well Knight bc2 is would be provoking
and the white would have to take on D4
for sure but now maybe just Knight the
moves away to F5 for example so after
that already Bishop goes back to D2
black knight from the center ever moves
then white will step back and try to
eliminate this piece
is it too rough if white goes black goes
rookie 3 and G5
wow sacrificing here to do that no fear
at all Rook taste Bishop on the board
wow
that would not have even been on my
radar sacrificing in an end game but the
whole idea is tactical he's going to
break apart White's Pawn chain once he's
kicked the night away and Magnus looks
up at the screen the evaluation bar
doesn't react meaning this sacrifice is
well Justified and Magnus looking
pretty happy there on the camera you've
got to say looking away as if he's just
kind of proud of his move proud of his
idea
looks nice I'm gonna admit yes it
certainly looks nice and as bearing in
mind that Shaq is in a must-win
situation and his wide works are just
not coordinating well Knight has to move
the E2 Pawn will drop and then Shaq just
has to get on with the job of relocating
The Rook on A4 which is doing nothing
yeah where to put that note that's the
first question does he centralize it
potentially at the cost of a pawn I
think Knight D5 is the only move for
white
he hesitated there Mama jarov that
Knight is it going to get ignored is it
going to get captured
Magnus gives a check
the white king where to go now
the go back I think all the way to G1
running away it has to as you say flee
back to the corner but now can't uh
Magnus to Simply trade Knights and step
back and grab those Pawns
we're expecting Magnus to trade off
white tonight that's the best piece
right now as you say Ivanka take this
one and then somehow maybe go back for
this Pawn that's your idea yeah it's
also tempted to actually grab the pawn
on D3 immediately with a knight exactly
Knight D3 and then Knight D5 and G4
to F3
if you can come to F3 with any of the
knights this black king is simply uh the
white king sorry is going to be caught
in a box and mated but of course there
are several ideas it's only that for
black it's uh tricky what to choose out
of the several options what would you
choose Judith here Magnus only needs a
draw he can choose a safer option if he
needs which one's very much tempted to
go Knight D3 I'm not sure that's the
best but um I somehow would go Knight D3
and Knight E5 or Knight E1 at some point
then G4
you love that 91 move it keeps happening
this tournament
full board Vision there not E1 coming in
watch out for that to happen Judith's
predicted it correctly every time I
think that is D3 on the board Magnus
makes a bit of a face he knew that was a
difficult decision and he's under two
minutes
so he needs to speed up what's mamajarov
gonna do to complicate the issue with
this white Rook on A4 as you said to
Ivanka just worst place worst piece was
placed peace on the board
where to go what to do not easy it's
certainly not easy and also you have to
bear in mind that black has ideas of
anchoring a knight on F3 so and that
would be curtains for the white king
I was looking at moves like 95 trying to
get the Knight immediately in with check
it's very powerful as well yeah and okay
I mean White's only move is actually to
try and trade off Rooks
and that's going to be a very difficult
job as well well now White's only plan
can be that after Knight E5 he goes Rook
F2
black snakes are so beautiful right now
Magnus will be reluctant to move them
but he really has to speed up he's got
about one minute 10 seconds now and it's
still 12 13 moves before he gets any
increment at all so he has to make
minimum 12 or 13 moves in one minute and
he's looking away from the board
what's this he needs to hurry up
it's going to be physically difficult
he's playing G5 G4 immediately well this
allows Knight F6 check grabbing a pawn
the Knight can check and take the
support next move
but this would lead maybe to a draw
because after check game goes out Knight
to G4 I think Black Goes H5
yeah White's night is kicked all the way
back
to the Knight F3 and Knight even some
kind of perpetuation but the problem is
Knight F3 is such a serious threat if
the Black Knight arrives there then you
have um check mating ideas with the Rook
taking H2 massive threat on the board
another jar of under three minutes now
has to deal with this one I think I
would just give this check now and just
hope to survive if you don't have any
options as my major if you should just
try and play quickly not give Magnus
time to think
calculation needs to be done of course
but he has plenty of times for a moment
two and a half minutes
and if he calculates uh ahead then he
can play his moves not only one but
several moves quickly yeah but Magnus
will do the same
to pause now or to pause later that's
the question I agree with the featured
chat just flag him just move not too
many options here from amajarov I'm
looking for others maybe he can hit the
there is something yeah hit one of the
Black Knights with his Rook
that must be the only real alternative
maybe you can yeah it's just so
difficult he just needs to decide as the
featured chat says white has definitely
got ideas of sacrificing on the B6
Square later for white a pawn to run
through but first you have to deal with
your king so he actually steps back with
his Knight trying to trade off makes a
lot of sense as well but right now maybe
Knight F3 is also possible I know
because takes a knight D3
and uh there we see a trade of knights
and again Magnus now has to play very
quickly and advances his F Pawn and
Magnus has a dream position all his
pieces are well placed and why its works
are just not coordinated
yeah Rooks thrive on open files and if
you notice Magnus has blocked every
single open file but look at this a
sacrifice in the air watch out for Rook
takes Pawn followed by the white Pawn
promoting we mentioned something similar
earlier this white a pawn is White's
only hope
oh
and okay is it on the cards now that's
the question Rook takes Pawn
Magnus he's allowed it to happen if root
takes porn maybe is he going to ignore
that there's some counter attacks
against the white king and okay now the
Black Knight has stepped back he defends
everything no sacrifices available and
whites Rooks looking for those open
files can he plug that open file with
his Knight with the Black Knight
he's going to have to and Magnus now
under 20 seconds oh we see a cross next
to magnus's move that means a missed
opportunity maybe there was something
stronger well maybe now rookie 2 can be
unpleasant or at least fighting
fighting for something from White's
point of view on the board we're going
to see the Rooks leave the board Knight
comes in
Black's night has lost a lot of power
with that trade of Rooks now it's going
to be incredibly tough to stop White's
Rook from infiltrating later but he's
using his King Magnus aggressively it's
going to be a race simply and who's
ahead here
Black's pawns running
um black spawn is really running
but the a pawn is so close
whites Rook has to get greedy here
simply has to capture the pawn and hope
for the best
Shack's being accurate so far as
mentioned in the future chat but is it
enough to win black sports are so fast
yeah but after C2 yeah this was a smart
move I believe
very smart covering the promotion
squares are now black will simply
threaten to push his pawn it might cost
white his Rook unless now he abandons
the defense of his a pawn seven seconds
for black
yeah
he's got a one second increment now but
that's no luxury it's uh not enough one
second over the board okay
White's gonna move his Rook very tricky
position what's he played Rook C2 but
that gives up the A6 Pawn
gives up the A6 pawn and look his pawns
are running now Shaq looks away even at
the cost of the Black Knight Magnus is
gonna win the game the Pawn's too strong